the art world is stunned they are
shocked they can't believe it this
morning after the astonishing
record-breaking sale of a rare
masterpiece Leonardo da Vinci's Salvator
Mundi was auctioned last night for more
than listen to this price hold on to
your pearls 450 million dollars easily
surpassing previous records the buyer is
anonymous two weeks ago that painting
that depicts Jesus was here look at that
Charlie made an appearance in studio 57
we were in the same room don't need to
cope will joins us now with the latest a
buyer is anonymous I think we can say we
are not the buyer yes yeah that's why
we're sitting here it's a staggering
staggering sum of money for our work of
art once thought lost to history forever
but with a price tag of nearly half a
billion dollars someone now possesses
the only privately held da Vinci
painting in the world and the bragging
rights that go along with it he'll give
me 120 inside an overflowing auction
house in New York City you could be to
90
packed with some eager to add to their
collection pull on a minute and others
who just wanted to bask in the spectacle
history was on sale they're not a source
of money selling here at Christie's 400
million dollars dissipate and the piece
is so throw in some 50 million dollars
worth of fees and this da Vinci one of
fewer than 20 paintings the Italian
Renaissance master ever created now
finds itself in the record books tonight
was definitely the most exciting moment
of my career Christie's co-chairman Alex
Roeder took the winning bid over the
phone there was no chitchat there was no
banter especially at these price levels
painted by DaVinci on a walnut panel in
the 1500s it was once owned by King
Charles the first but then vanished only
to reappear the turn of the 20th century
changing hands a number of times likely
by some who had no idea what they were
holding when I realized what it was I
was I was frightened art collector Roger
Simon acquired the piece in 2005 but
doubted the 26 inch tall oil painting
was a true Da Vinci so here was
something that was thought to be lost
could then be studied and looked at it
was scary
but also I was aware of a kind of the
importance of it and again some art
experts maintain that the painting is a
replica saying the heavy wear and
restoration masks the authors the true
author of the work and it was said to be
sold by a Russian billionaire who bought
it in 2013 for nearly a hundred and
twenty eight million dollars we are told
now that the painting will be leaving
DaVinci's we don't know the buyer but we
can tell you he paid more than double
the previous record for a painting at
auction big jump in price honey how do
we know it's a he what cuz what good
does it do to have bragging rights if
nobody knows who you are
I wouldn't want somebody to know nobody
wasn't over she's had some major art
where it was a top secret that no one
knew I know this isn't one well when it
was here it looked like you guys weren't
even breathing next to it yes it's true
yeah it could be a country to back in
2005 it was only ten thousand dollars
amazing Tony thank you thank you Tony